Emily Maynard is pregnant the  bachelorette star who now goes by her  married name Emily Johnson had made the  announcement on her blog she wrote quote  I truly couldn't be more excited and I  said about two weeks after Jennings was  born that I couldn't wait to have  another I just had a no clue it would  happen and so quickly Emily did it just  give birth to her second child son and  Jennings lasted July quote I guess I  should have read that part in the baby  handbook that says you're super fertile  after giving birth huh baby number three  will join Big Brother Jennings in about  six months  Jennings is Emily's first child with her  husband at Tyler the couple will  celebrate their two-year anniversary  this summer and Emily of course also has  a ten-year-old daughter Ricki